[Music]
once again like to thank you all for
coming out in this great snowstorm that
we've been having to share your time as
he shows real dedication you know no
pain no gain right okay this game was
played Michael tall was white against
Anatoly luta cough it was from a Tollan
team tournament that was played in 1964
not today you know a modern day
tournament practice man you know they're
looking at variations 20 30 moves deep
and some of them you know some of these
top guys have worked out things to an
endgame advantage and it's really
remarkable how deep chess theory has
become but in these days in 1964 when
this game was played I mean it was a
wild wild west as far as as opening
theory went and a lot of creativity in
the openings before things business
before the encyclopedia Chesham openings
was never published so imagine that your
opponent just trots out d5 well there
goes your preparation just two moves
along already how many of you seen this
counter gambit d5 Julian I hear you you
know
is it called the elephant gambit then
this is the elephant okay well there you
go
I mean the yellow you got the orangutan
going for you now you got the elephant
gambit right so it was white what are
you supposed to do well there's really I
I don't see any
any choice you take it okay then the guy
goes like e for now this were to work
for black it would mean like ephors it's
not playable and I mean because y-you
know blacks taking the initiative like
on move to and if this is a good
position for black well you know again
you just can play you farm but it can't
be great for black but you know you're
the board and you've got to solve the
problem your opponents coming out after
your all guns blazing right what are you
gonna do well obviously if you move your
knight whether it be to e5 or d4 the
reaction Queen takes d5 will attack the
knight and blacks gonna be doing okay so
you're pretty much obliged to play Queen
e2 you know pinning the pawn and you
know if things go your way you get to
play D 3 and yes soon you'll be two
bonds up you'll refute the elephant
gambit f5 and this guy is just not not
backing down he's not playing Queen c7
like after a move like Queen e7 well we
were we'd probably be happy here with
white because at least after Queenie 7
once we move our Knight and you're not
playing Queen takes d5 and after white
plays Knight c3 and d3 I mean I don't
see sufficient compensation for the pond
then an f5 man that's an in-your-face
kind of move that just basically says
hey listen if you don't do anything I'm
going to play Knight f6 and I'm gonna
take my pawn back and I'm gonna boot
your knight on f3 so white plays the
most principled move d3 Knight f6 pawn
takes e4
pawn takes e4 and again the same
reasoning applies if black could play
Queen takes d5 or and he's just gonna
have a great game so Knight c3 Bishop b4
and again if black can play castles he's
on the attack
check c6 Queen takes pawn takes so so
far you know like I can follow things
pretty okay and I think blacks position
is bad but how bad I mean once again if
black could play moves like pawn takes
and knight c6 is Kings a little bit
stuck somehow you know our Queen kind of
carves up the f8 square so okay white
should be for choice but it's kind of
weird
so Bishop g5 develop right on tags
castles 96 Queen a3 now let me get the
pawn count again three six three six
okay so now it looks like white in fact
has refuted blacks whole opening concept
blacks King is stuck in the center and
rook e1 check is threatening amongst
other things maybe rook takes d5 Knight
takes d5 as well Bishop e6 covers those
threats now I thought that the move
I thought G takes f 3 wasn't so bad for
black I'm know I'm beginning to wonder
why I thought it wasn't so bad for black
still looks bad
towel played Bishop c4 very nice right
I mean in such a position
you want to play G takes f three but
then if you think about it and you said
okay if I want to play G takes f three
what would be my next move I won upon
what would be my next movement and my
next move and in a sense if you're kind
of like just you know took this position
and saw it for the first time and I said
to you what would be the ideal squares
for whites pieces you would say well
without question we're gonna go rook on
h1 to e1 because that's an ideal open
file but since that's illegal you can't
you've got to move the bishop so then we
said oh okay I get it now we're gonna
move our bishop first and then we're
gonna play rook H e1 and everything's
going to be great and then you say well
I'll move my Bishop to b5 because that's
a really cool move I mean it pins the
knight to the king it prepares the
development of the rook and so forth and
so on but it turns out that well Bishop
C force is simply much stronger move
because after Bishop b5 although the
knight is in a pin it doesn't there's no
real threat you don't want to really
take this Knight with the bishop on b5
well let it's a real threat you do want
to take this pawn which would just open
up the floodgates to blacks position
Queen e7 so black is kind of waking up
to the smell of bacon and it's as Oh
bacon that's being a fried here so with
Queen e7 this is a kind of on remove I
mean in a sense after Queen takes e7
Knight take c7 Bishop takes f6 G f95
wholesale exchanges you take this pawn
you'll eventually with it back and
you'll get yourself in some major rook
ending upon a head and maybe it's a win
maybe it's not maybe it's not maybe
black and draw so Queen e7 pretty cool
move so then you start to look and think
okay how about Bishop takes F
Queen takes a three B takes a three G
takes f6 take on d5 or maybe rook e1
King f7 take on d5 and again whites and
all of these variations whites winning a
pond but if his structure ends up
getting double pawns or something it's
not good really really convincing so tau
plays Knight takes d5 and you know we
kind of get it
obviously Knight takes d5 Bishop takes
a7 is unplayable so Queen takes a three
and now you know like just kind of like
before we automatically recapture the
Queen it occurs to us hey Eve stop
there's a swishing Zook
I can play Knight takes f6 with a check
but after G takes f6 you know so many
pieces are hanging that's wrong I can
play Knight East seven check oh that's
kind of cool because after ninety seven
check you can't walk to d8 or f8 because
then I take that Bishop I check and he
can't go to f7 so I go ninety seven
check all right and then he's got to go
King e7 but then what do I have I gotta
take the Queen he takes my Bishop I go
rook check he goes even has a Bishop e2
so it kind of gets complicated right so
what move did Michael tall play Michael
tall is white
Deitz Issa okay
let's see the $32,000 is this incorrect
yes yes yeah well I must say that when I
saw White's next move I just like whoa
this was just too cool right I mean
white just lost his queen but obviously
after you capture the Queen Bishop takes
c4 or you have to ask what it is that
white has done isn't that just amazing
move right
I mean blacks are queen up Mike shaquita
and blacks are clean up and lost I mean
this is like wow only move Queen c5
check now you can't move to f7 that's
walking into some double checks King f7
rook takes f6 is a is a check
pick check thank you
takes takes so now the smoke is kind of
cleared right but you know like as a kid
I'm thinking to myself well man all
black gets to take that pot on G - that
would just be tremendous and wait a
minute if I miscounted here something
isn't like black and exchange ahead
right so blacks in exchange ahead if he
can play if he has time to play F takes
G to or rook b8 I mean what's the
problem
check first thing is you can't go back
to e8 because Bishop check and night II
6 will be made into King steps up check
no the King can't step up again it has
to go back check check
bishop here attacking the knight i mean
black must have been itching to capture
this pawn on g2 for like the last 12
moves you know it's like he's never
getting the chance to capture this pawn
on g2 night before was played Bishop
takes f3 and now unfortunately became a
bad blunder bye-bye black but we already
this position is actually very very good
for white he's actually ahead material
and after something like maybe rook to
e8 the rook would come to h6 this night
would come back this is just a crass
blunder oh sorry there's actually this
move Knight takes a to grabbing the pawn
that was just simply wrong rook takes
Knight takes King b6 Knight takes g5 is
a is a great ending for white and why
could even throw in a 2 a 3 if he likes
this one ends up losing a piece this was
very clever by Talde now I'm sure that
black was thinking okay I just attacked
the night and then the knight would move
and I move my knight back but now the
problem is black can't play the desired
King to d6 because Knight takes actually
has a threat of f7 and a2 is hanging and
after King d7 check 93 and the knight on
8 who is trapped
sweet right I mean just but the the
creative genius that went into the setup
were I don't know I mean I was just to
me that was just like wow amazing to
just give up your queen and it's not
like forecheck I didn't get it right
right right away the next game that I'd
like to show it actually has some great
theory that's very important today how
many of you play Kings Indian defense
now this was a from the candidates match
in I'm probably mispronouncing it your
soul 1969 bent Larsen was white Michael
tall black this was game 5 in that match
c4 and g6 Knight c3 Bishop g7 e4 by the
way just a quick mention about this
particular move order if white had
played the move d4 he bent in this case
would have given in his opponent
Michael tall an opportunity to switch
defenses and go into a grünfeld defense
and in those years it was considered
absolutely wrong for white to develop
his knight on f3 in a mainline Greenfeld
instead they were trying to develop the
knight on two so the idea of the movie
for is in a sense if black is going to
play King's India no big deal but if
black was going to play AG room fell
defense this line of play for white is
intended
to avoid Greenfeld pets so ii for now
came d6 d4 castles Bishop e2 so again a
lot of a lot of theory was happening in
the Kings Indian really in the 50s and
60s and before World War 2 of course
thanks mainly to the efforts of David
Bronstein the root of all evil
David was was one most creative opening
geniuses ever like if you just go
through the e Co I mean you can't open a
chapter where David Bronstein doesn't
say the suggestion or recommendation he
was amazing
and David Bronstein and FM Geller both
those two guys more than anybody really
blaze the Kings Indian defense trails
and then you know new generations of
players Michael Paul Garry Kasparov came
and played the Kings Indian FF
thereafter but at this at this time in
the history literally this position was
at abia and not just this position but
91 like today a lot of player strangely
enough like play the move Knight d2 but
in those days 91 was considered the
range everybody and his brother played
91 Knight d7 and then you have what is
known as the Mar del Plata variation
this idea for white g4f and what what's
white idea is actually to fianchetto his
knight on g2 this is kind of cool idea
and White's idea very cold-bloodedly
funnily enough is to play h4 and instead
of giving
black this nice Kings Indian defend
attack that he likes white is playing to
gain space on the kingside as well a
very honorary way of play that he won 97
not g4 bit in those days night d3 and
we're still not there yet but here it
comes
f5 Bishop d2 Knight of 6 f3 f4 c v g5
rook c1 so really this position was like
the standard line of the Kings Indian
for white light like chess it evolved to
this point and everybody who played the
white side of the Kings Indian played
this position and why the idea is is
that it's quite clear that the battle
lines are being drawn why it's gonna
play on the Queen side blacks in a play
on the Kings side but with this
particular setup of Bishop and Knight
white always has the opportunity of
playing Knight f2 to slow down g4 and
then put the pawn on h3 and in
combination first of all the pieces look
kind of harmonious from White's point of
view but in combination with slowing
black down on the Kings side comes this
idea playing Knight to b5 take-take-take
Bishop to b4 or with the knight on b5
and the rook on the C file jumping to c7
and so on also if we can imagine the
knight coming to b5 the knight coming to
f2 the pawn coming to age 3 sometimes
the rooks lit up to the c3 square to
defend the King side along the 3rd rank
so for all of these reasons this was
considered best play for white rook
Siwon and tall came up with an
incredible idea not this move this move
is not incredible this move was very
normal
Knight g6 Knight b5 ruck f7 C takes D
six C takes D six so first of all we're
very very impressed by this whole
organization by black moving as night
around moving his rook around now with
rook coming to f7 it's it has a
multi-purpose idea first of all we're
trying to defend c7 secondly sometimes
this rook steps to the G file when the
bishop drops back also very importantly
please do note that Queen check does not
win a piece thanks to night at f2 and
the knight on b5 is defended okay so far
so good
and Larsson played in direct style clean
c2 okay
like really reinforcing his threat
so from White's point of view Peyman
Knight c7 is really really huge because
after 97 you move your rook to b8 i play
96 and strategically black is lost just
it just lost because as most Kings
Indian defense players know that when
you get into these types of attacks on
the King side if I take off the light
squared Bishop your attack is is is
garbage you
it's over so my threat is so
overwhelmingly strong night c7 followed
by night X that you as black you're
absolutely positively compelled you must
you must play the move 98 there's no ifs
ands or buts about it that's what you
gotta do you gotta play 98 but when you
play the move 98 you have to recognize
that this defensive move it's now going
to cost you extra time to be able to
play g5 and g4 that is to say white can
play Knight up to h3 and when you kick
this Knight backwards and this night
will go backwards you'll have to reload
on the the King site for example in a
game between Yvonne Chuck and chop arena
in this position after 98 night F to h5
let me just show you a recent game in
modern chess so to speak between two
excellent grandmasters
again Evon shock was white in this game
here we have a very typical whoops Kings
Indian play G for F takes G for Knight
f6 Bishop II 1 and White had an
advantage and went on to win this game
and again it was very important to note
that the two tempies that black spent
playing 98 and Knight f6 obviously meant
that his attack was slowed down so after
Queen c2 Michael Tao did not play the
forced move 98 he went for g4 BAM
that's what we call it in your face move
I mean it's like challenge g4 well of
course we don't want to take the pawn on
g4 because that would hang the pawn on
e4 so we just let black do his thing and
we'll play Knight c7 of course 97 G
takes G takes and now black of course is
busted right because his rook is hanging
in the moment you move your rook then we
play 97 and black a strategically lost
because he's missing his attacking light
squared Bishop Black has no choice
Bishop h3 hanging a rook Knight takes a
8 and Knight takes e4 is the move
well this is a walk on the wild would
you say sure good let me take a quick
poll what's happening here who thinks
White's winning not much supporters for
bed I guess everybody knows that this is
tall a tall tale isn't it but forgetting
the fact of the players who the players
are what really do you think is going on
in the position White's a rook up is
white winning black winning black
winning draw perpetual okay all right
let's see what happens so Knight takes
e4 well we'll take that one too
YUM
Queen g5 check King f2 and White's King
is going on a journey it's clear that
white has in mind King King King and in
the meantime Queen h4 check King g1
Queen g5 checking Black has a perpetual
black has remember in the earlier
lecture I said that so many of tall's
combinations featured positions where he
really wasn't taking a risk to all can
see that he has a perpetual check now he
wants to see if he has more yet tile
play Queen G to check King H one night
h4
yee-yee a critical moment okay
so White's a rook ahead but White's not
feeling too good you know like it sure
looks to me like blacks having a lot of
fun over
here you look at a piece Thank You Ben
you can count better than I can count me
pretty good but White's facing F 2 F 4 F
3 attacking the bishop on e 2 which
protects the rook on F one other bad
things include things like Queen takes
e4 Bishop takes h1 ideas and it looks
bad but White has a wimp White has a wit
ok and you tell me what whites with it
Bishop takes f4 why would that win ah my
head hurts
Bishop takes f4 G takes f 4 knight takes
f4 so ripped it ok well let's have fun
let's let's take a look at it
naturally the one move I didn't look at
before my lecture it was suggested by
pre Bishop takes F for G takes I would
be very reluctant to to do this if I
were white just on the general grounds
that I'm opening up that Bishop on g7
but beyond that what's a a direct
refutation might be can we just look at
this for a second if I take this makes
h3 check weird
I can't go to d1 because of Knight e3
check I I'm reckoning I have to go here
right
let's see do I have check
IIIi don't want to shame myself by
suggesting that I wanted to play rook c7
so I I won't mention that that was an
idea of mine I could take a night with
check here here here it looks like
whites escaping let's go back for a
second so Bishop takes F let me just
take another look at this move for a
second new variation here no how do i
how do I get you
check-check is that okay huh
Wow
I'm confused so if I go check yeah that
look box and if I go check 23 looks all
kind of forcing right unfortunately my
night is hanging on h4 I don't like that
one and now let me pause for a second
it's it's great that my bishop on h3
defends c8 but I'm afraid I'm losing
here hmm very interesting Bishop takes
f4 so GF Knight takes f4 one more look
here ah ah then you're king that was
clever I'm looking at Queen g5 so what
the idea behind cream g5 was intended to
do is to take away your squared D 2 so
you can't run with your kings so for
example after this this check you can't
go to d2
maybe have to go to d2 anyway because c2
is with check I'll have a I'll have a
perpetual if you don't go yes yeah yes
sir back so Bishop takes f4 G takes f
for knight takes f4 and you in this
particular moment night okay sorry sorry
sorry
Oh Knight age for Bishop takes pawn
takes knight takes I don't see a chance
for Knight f3 check no yeah okay let's
see what we were up to I think it was
Queen g5 here that looks like a
reasonable move I'd also just keep in
mind that this is at the board right so
your clock's ticking yeah and you know
your Kings running and your opponent may
have a perpetual check when he likes so
this makes it very very difficult for
you one of your extra pieces obviously
is this knight on a 8 out of the game at
the moment now so let's leave it at
Queen g5 leaves a situation messy so
we're looking for a clean win and Bishop
f4 ain't it now so again from black from
White's perspective his I mean I would
be terrified of the move f3 which in
connection with this Queen and rook
Queen and Bishop pardon me hitting my
rook
I got issues but funnily enough if after
f3 our bishop could fly away it wouldn't
be so bad but our knight on d3 is in the
way which leads us to logically conclude
Knight f2 pardon me what did I do wrong
oh thank you
Knight f2 wins for white we can meet the
move f2 f3 by simply moving our Bishop
and our King has got the d1 square
anybody see any ideas here for for white
after and for black pardon me after
night Knight f2
I didn't either
I mean the best I could come up with
with something like night check King d1
Knight d4 Queen c3 or queen d3 queen c3
I think with ideas like Queen takes h3
and why it's okay so it means that tall
should have taken the perpetual check
that was on offer earlier but
unfortunately for bent then did not find
the brilliant night f2 no hold on this
is okay variation this is second
he played instead of night f2 oh that
was because the I didn't put the game in
Oh oops Bishop e3 whoa Bishop e3
now is this brilliant or baffling or
what would okay so what was Ben's idea
Ben's idea is simply that he really
loved to trade queens he is after all a
rook and a piece ahead
so if black were to take his bishop
Ben's idea is that he would play rook
takes King cakes and then Bishop h5
check and thanks to the discovered
attack he'd be able to trade Queens and
win the game so with the move Bishop III
he bent understood that the bishop was
actually untouchable also from Ben's
point of view is he scared to death like
me of the move f3 but with the move
Bishop III he's hoping for f3 so he can
play rook g1 all right
so unfortunately tall didn't fall out of
the script tall didn't take the bishop
he didn't push his pawn instead Michael
Bishop played what don't all shout out
at once so what alternatives are there
for black
Queen h2 damn it
are you something like a queen h2 didn't
you know maybe after Queen h2 will move
our Bishop back and then Bishop
f2 and I'll be safe ah Queen takes e4 I
like that move centralizing your queen
okay
attacking the bishop some positions this
now that the if the bishop moves
there'll be a pin that makes the move
Bishop takes a f-1 possible so Queen
takes e4 then Bishop f2 I think was
played then f3 I think was played and
then Bishop takes h4 damn I should know
this yeah okay Queen takes h4 check
night f2 pawn takes eetu
greentech seat
so the physician has cleaned up a little
bit
White's a piece ahead rook ahead I beg
your pardon and if he gets his chance
not saying but just if he can get his
chance any ideas of rook you know
swingin over to the Kings side would be
very very much appreciated Bishop takes
f1 really isn't a good move in many of
the variations because of a rook c8 Shaq
I think so so what did Michael tal play
here black to play he says he's just a
rubdown or is he yeah for now it's very
very hard to know really at the board
how much of the Salton Sea but I mean
I'm gonna go we saw the guy loses Queen
and make a quiet room now he's down a
rook use kind of makes us quiet move but
it's an awesome quiet move it's not
really quiet at all in fact it's kind of
thunderous if you think about it well
first of all with the movie for you're
threatening to play III and after Queen
takes III rookie sevens gonna cause an
accident secondly with the movie for not
only you introducing that battering ram
kind of idea but this Bishop on g7
that's been sleeping well it's also been
protecting the King so it's not
completely asleep has ideas like Bishop
to d4 once again reinforcing Eve heart
be for e3 ideas so II for
I just think that's this is a great okay
so now bent came up with something kind
of interesting here okay he started his
defense kind of going backwards a bit he
started thinking that his knight on a 8
is a really really rotten piece but it
does have one positive aspect about it
it covers the square c7 protects the
square c7 in other words then starts to
imagine that after e3 Queen takes III
rook C rook to e7 winning his Queen rook
the c7 would be great if the rook on e7
were pinned so then besides that since
the bishop coming here is a threat he
will play the move rook g1 huh clever
boy so what's his idea if you play III
Queen takes III rookie 7 rook takes g7
check King takes g7 then rook c7 and
white wins in the meantime not only does
this move stop III but the bishop is
pinned and if white is probably thinking
to himself please please PLEASE if I can
play rook g3 I'll make an effective
blockade so against this very clever
defense what did Michael tall do
and I'll shout out at wine yes very good
he played III cream take c3 very good
can you take c7 so in a sense tal fell
for it right
he let white execute his defense and now
the shifty seven only move rook takes d7
only moved rook takes d7 and now the
smoke has cleared that wait a minute
you know it's two rooks four zero two
rooks two nights for a ruck but the
knight on a 8 estate is trapped so in
order to rescue his knight white bent
played Queen takes a 7 okay
pretty pretty amazing situation and now
well rookie 7 check here I mean I just
give both both players a great deal of
credit for this game because I just
think it's a fantastic game and here
unfortunately bent was in a little bit
of time trouble he could and should have
played the move King F 1 and I think
that white is worse after the move King
F 1 let me just show you what he did in
the game and what he missed
after the MU King d1 came this fabulous
move Queen C 4 and suddenly it's very
clear that White's pieces are
discombobulated this Queen a knight over
here the the kind of hanging in the air
this night on on f2 and conversely
blacks Queen and rook cordon
coordinating very nicely dominate the
position and queen F 1 is a decisive
threat after Queen
b6 was played check on f1 king D to
Brooke II to check the game didn't last
very long here here here here
oops that didn't happen sorry King d4
sorry King d4 happened over right queen
III check King here rook c2 and then
gave it a rest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]